los orígenes raciales y étnicos ya no
serán un motivo para admitir estudiantes
en Estados Unidos El argumento las
políticas de admisión conscientes de la
raza son equivalentes a discriminación
racial Harvard y la universidad de
Carolina del Norte ya habían recibido
demandas sin éxito por este tema y
recientemente el activista conservador
Edward Bloom llevó el caso a la Corte
Suprema
no se puede curar la discriminación
racial que ocurrió en el pasado con la
nueva discriminación de hoy
las políticas de admisión en cuestión
tenían en cuenta la raza entre otros
factores al elegir entre candidatos
cualificados e históricamente las
políticas han promovido la diversidad la
diversidad de Michigan tuvo que detener
su política de admisión diversa en 2006
y en los 15 años siguientes la matrícula
de afroamericanos cayó del 7 al 4%. pero
los jueces conservadores de la corte
decidieron que la raza no podía ser un
factor en las admisiones universitarias
el presidente biden citó a las voces
disidentes en la Corte Suprema la
disidencia establece la decisión de hoy
cita hace retroceder décadas de Progreso
trascendental y precedente fin de la
cita estoy de acuerdo con esa
declaración de los disidentes
agregando que la discriminación Todavía
existe en Estados Unidos Mientras tanto
la derecha estadounidense saludó el
fallo como una victoria para la
meritocracia el expresidente Donald
Trump calificó el jueves como un gran
día para Estados Unidos y su principal
rival para las primarias republicanas
Run de santis dijo que la decisión acaba
con la discriminación por parte de los
colegios y universidades
seis de los nueve jueces de la Corte
Suprema Fueron designados por
presidentes republicanos y la línea
conservadora fue noticia el año pasado
por anular el derecho constitucional al
aborto